although I'm hopeful about the
individual I'm very fearful about the
direction that politically this country
is going hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer
freezing TV and here is Jonathan Hoenig
portfolio manager of capitalist pig
hedge fund he's also a frequent guest on
Fox News and Fox Business on shows like
Cavuto and bulls and bears Jonathan
thanks for having us my pleasure if you
could just explain what a hedge fund is
in a simple simple language hedge fund
is simply a pool of money investors pool
their money and point a manager to make
those decisions hedge funds can invest
in essentially almost anything from
plain old stocks and bonds to part
pipeline pipeline partnerships or
commodities for an exchange that's
primarily where I deals in the foreign
exchange market but they get a bad rap
because they are profit-seeking I mean
we have the sense now that well if a
hedge fund is profiting someone else be
must be losing that money in fact it's
it's very much just the opposite you
recently ran the first hedge fund to add
in cranes business in over 80 years it
was made technically illegal during the
Great Depression how did you go about
doing this and what are you hoping to
accomplish with it well it's technically
still illegal I mean hedge funds are not
allowed to advertise that's been
regulations that have been to places the
the early 1930s and there's some
movement to change those I said no I
want to be first in fact I want to run
an ad that celebrates individualism
celebrates freedom celebrates free
markets so of course I had to choose a
quote by Iran but it was my way of
saying look you investors are our profit
seeking yes but they're also completely
moral they're beneficial there there
there a benefit to this country the
quote for they add that used by ein r
and it said we've got to make the most
of like now because we probably don't
have an afterlife or something to that
if you're a big proponent of Rand why do
you think she's still relevant in
America today Iran's influence in
relevance is growing and a directive an
objective
influence and relevance is is growing
and you see it all across the the
political and cultural landscape think
especially as people are waking up to
the importance of ideas and the reality
that ideas matter in fact that's what
that guides a country and you can look
at the prosperity the relative
prosperity of a country like America and
the total hellhole of a country like
North Korea or Cuba and say well you
know is the water so fundamentally
different in Pyongyang North Korea as it
is in Chicago no it's the ideas that
govern a country that governed a
civilization that govern our culture
that's what determines its its success
do you think we're moving closer to or
further away from Rams ideals I'm
hopeful for the future I'm truly hopeful
for the future when I see what what man
can do when he's left free to achieve to
accomplish to think how can you not be
hopeful that's why when I anyway look at
these buildings when I when I use my
iphone when I you know explore all
that's going on that's exciting in this
world I am tremendously hopeful but I'm
also fearful at the same time because I
see so many out there whose purpose is
to destroy only to destroy I think
there's a very fearful Neil ISM now
that's growing in America maybe it's
replacing a religion after so many years
but it's simply destruction for
destructions sake and you see it in this
collectivist ideology I think that its
president everything from the welfare
state to regulation to more
redistribution of wealth I mean those
are the big topics that seem to be
talked about in political circles and
that really worries me so you know
although I'm hopeful about the
individual I'm very fearful about the
direction that politically this country
is going as a financial expert well what
do you think which is the most important
thing that Americans should be pursuing
right now in terms of economic recovery
for four years now Washington has like
thrown literally every idea at the wall
of how to create economic growth how to
no stimulus after stimulus and let's
subsidize this and try this and try that
of course it's all failed miserably or
you know 15 trillion dollars and debts
unemployment I mean you've heard all the
statistic
the one thing they haven't tried is
freedom right that's the one thing
that's never on the table deregulation
lowering and flattening of the tax code
opening up new markets opening up trade
that never on the table of course that's
the one remedy that the economy really
needs and so in that regard does it
doesn't matter who's going to win the
election between Obama and Romney I
think it matters very much I'm not a
Romney supporter but I feel like to some
extent we're in a sinking ship of the
sinking ship I think is the president's
collectivist self-sacrificial philosophy
it frankly scares me and although Mitt
Romney is by no means the perfect
candidate I think they can hopefully buy
us some time to educate the culture
about the wrong direction in which we're
going Jonathan thank you again for
having us my pleasure friesen TV I'm
Tracy Oppenheimer
you